[Applaudissements]
il viendra nous voir
est ce que la nouvelle épisode de
derrick oui oui vous le savez l'un est
bien sûr un cyril s'est présenté à la
présidence de france télé et du conte en
train d'adapter un petit peu les
programmes on a commencé par derrick
voilà on est en train de créer la série
au fur et à mesure c'est un derrick un
petit peu différent plus en mode cyril
quoi mais vous allez voir ça suit les
mêmes aventures quand même vous suivez
d'eric girard oui notre amérique où le
déroulement de maisons de retraite juste
avant les grosses têtes
ils étaient autres derek wills note
d'eric vous les voulez mais je connais
surtout votre voulais vraiment être
président et vous si vous
oui vous voyez girard a mais je vous est
serrée cette voie si je veux être
présidente rappelait mairie de france 2
ouais ah oui en ce 3 france 4 vous
voulez quoi en retour ils font à 14 les
biens france 2 1 où les france 2 france
2 ouais quoi france 2 ou non le truc des
vieux des 300 francs stelios et france
télévisions
regarde nouvel épisode de derrick c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonjour specter qui se tient en curé et
tu veux ma photo non alors il est 8
heures saintes et j'en ai à [ __ ]
j'ai une rolex schindler et m'a pris
pour un bateau salut dix minutes à me
casser palais glaoui c'est pas le jour 1
d'orgueil sur ma vie j'en peux plus ça
fait trois mois j'ai paniqué angela est
maginot ursula m a dit walou haneke m à
10 matchs et gretel hamadini qu'on
boucle
c'est quoi le problème sans déconner et
si tu faisais péter une nouvelle veste
mais tu as raison sur la bm on va chez
mon cousin château cos prime à merveille
c'est exactement ce modèle que je veux
avec sage binic et je fais pas pour ça
il faut que 15%
c'est max allez va pour 15 terrasse pour
toutes mes tripes au choc et c'est moi
s'est dirigé au nouvelle affaire j les
patates au fond du sac
je vous laisse avanciez mois unique et
rebecca alors d league
je vais très claire entre toi et moi
sinon ouais c'est ça norway et tongs
routard mahé leno est allé dans ce cas
ça que naissent je suis dans une race
rassure ma vie même colombo et la bge et
rebecca
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est vraiment battu lundi quoi oui
mais je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
dit tout sur twitter ou sur book mais
vraiment moi je suis fan avant de se
quitter avec une dernière imagerie de
camille combal
je souhaite qu'on passe un pro